it's it's very brave for people
especially in our industry
to go oh i'm on this or i'm like people
think oh but that shows a weakness like
i've had surgeries i deal with pain
oh he's a liability no i'm just being
honest with the world and i mean
i do what i can and uh i just think it
helps
and again whatever whenever you talk
about this as i'm sure you're saying
we've talked about
it's not like prozec will work for
everybody prozac might work for you
so anyway go ahead in fact you know i
actually
well i share it because i think it's
important as you know
i just think i think vulnerability is
important and transparency
superpower i think it helps it feels
awkward and scary
to be that real uh but
it has only ever brought positive things
into mind and
other people's lives me too so i don't
want to hide
and not talk about the struggles that i
have particularly since we have the
platform that we do and i think that
the more we can normalize and we have
platforms to really spread that
normalization out there
so that's super helpful the only thing
that i've ever questioned
uh talking about the brand or type of
uh pharmaceutical is something that
actually i learned
was it when chris cause they'll give you
thank you as a spokesperson like oh he
says this
no it's not it's it's not even that it's
um it was something i heard kristen bell
saying it was either on your
podcast or was on um yeah on armchair
well she said she wouldn't name the
product because she doesn't want other
people
it was you know it was a mine where she
said yeah she doesn't want other people
to think exactly
right that doesn't work for them just
because it worked for her so she didn't
say
so that's exactly what i was alluding to
and i think that's and that's the only
hesitancy i even
have in talking with uh talking about
what i'm taking but i'm going to talk
about it
uh because we're also giving people the
um the uh
clarity in our conversation right now
that this
just because it works for me doesn't
mean it works for you and by the way i'm
not even sure it works for me
uh perfectly right now you know there's
things that work
uh and there's things that that don't
work when i um
well first tracking back a little bit so
again i was even though i was in like
really really really uh you know sad
shape and feeling super defeated and
uh lost and incapable uh
and you know all of the not good things
um i tried i still was like i i don't
want to
i don't want to have to take a pill if i
don't have to i'm going to do all of the
other things
and and things that i've done before but
i was really like
leaning into it i was praying
uh exercise meditating daily uh
20 20 minutes a day sometimes 40 minutes
a day
20 in the in the morning and 20 at night
um
[Music]
there's a great app by the way my friend
turned me on to if anybody's looking to
get into meditation
one giant mind write that down right
like
they walk you through um i thought
you're going to say j-date
isn't that for jews like myself i'm a
jew you're a giant
so so meditating um was working out
every day was eating the cleanest of
clean wasn't drinking any booze
and i still and it still was not
pulling me out of the depths
and it was terrifying and i was like
well
i i i can't if this is if i'm doing all
these things and it doesn't really feel
like i'm having consistent
uh market difference in the uptick of my
life
and i guess that's the sign that i do
need to try
something um and you know as it turned
out
had people like yourself or others who
were saying
you know zack maybe it's time that you
really give
an anti-depressant a shot